what was the clue again i think it was
10 of
pi minus x is equal to negative
tan x is that right okay good so
they give you a clue now by the way you
always need to look at a
clue very closely you need to stare at
it right you need to think about
what in the clue has any input or
usefulness to the question i've got
right now for me there is one
outstanding thing that's
similar between the clue and the
question
does anyone see it what outstanding
thing it's the pi
minus isn't it pi minus x here's a pi
minus but it doesn't matter that it's
messy
it's just that it happens to be long to
write so the question is how can i use
if this have an angle of some kind here
and 10 of that angle is going to be
relevant
right then i need to take 10 of both
sides
somehow okay now here's one of the
useful things for you which i sort of
glossed over before
we we talked about the problems we're
doing this sine
of sine inverse right we said this is
only equal to x when
between negative one and one
right because that's the restriction
that's where sine inverse exists right
but when you come to ten ten is
different
when you think about tan of ten inverse
you think about what's the equivalent of
this for ten inverse and the answer is
ten inverse exists for all real values
so you don't have a problem here
um it's equal to x for all real values
of x so therefore i can be a little more
fast and loose with tan right
i can just take tan of both sides and
it'll be okay
right now here's the thing though um i i
cannot take 10 on both sides here
because this is what i'm trying to prove
okay so i can't just say oh here's my
starting point and then off i go because
i will obviously end up with the right
answer even if what i start with is
wrong
so instead i would say i know
semantically it doesn't seem like
there's that big a deal
but i would say consider and then what i
want to cons i can't consider an
equation
an equation is a statement this equals
that
right so therefore i will consider
something which is relevant to this
statement isn't a statement itself for
instance
something like this oops
10 inverse 2 and
pi minus
this okay now i can consider these
separately
right i can consider 10 of this
and tan of this okay is this all right
furthermore i can consider what the
difference between them is
okay now i'm set up this is the thing
which i'm going to work with
okay so have a look piece by piece
what's this thing
this is double angle this is tan 2
theta x whatever you want to call it
okay so what's double angle
it's a 2 tan x in this case
10 inverse of 2
right on 1 minus 10
squared isn't it 1 minus 10 squared
of there's my angle is that okay
right now what's happening over here aha
there's my clue
okay so instead of writing that i'm
going to write this
okay so that is minus
plus because of the negative right tan
of
now what is the x right in this clue
it corresponds to cos inverse of three
fifths does it not
right uh let's see here cos inverse
of three fifths okay this guy left hand
type easy
what is this two times
two what's on the bottom
one minus four right so this is negative
three
is that okay you're content with that so
that'll be negative one three what is
this
okay well this is a tr i can put this in
a triangle can't i
three four five where's theta right
it's cos so it's adjacent it's this guy
up here
right so what's tan of that it's four on
three
now i've established that this thing is
equal to zero
that this thing is equal to zero right
therefore i can say those two are equal
those two terms up there
that's equal to this
okay yes and so on that basis
i can say well i don't need to worry
about the tens anymore if tan of the
angle is the same
then the angles will also be the same
you see what i've done okay so i've sort
of done a few different things here
number one
i thought very carefully about the clue
and therefore what shape i need to put
this into use it
secondly you can't start with this
equation and then go from there even
though it makes things a lot simpler
it doesn't hold water logically as a
proof okay you have to consider
something like this which is not a
statement of truth
work with it and then draw your
statement out from there
make sense